[Música]
los perros de pavlov es la frase que a
menudo resume la investigación del
doctor iván pavlov a principios del
siglo 20 donde demostró que podemos
alterar los estímulos que provocan un
acto reflejo en los perros lo hizo
sonando una campana justo antes de
alimentar a sus perros luego de sonar la
campana una y otra vez seguido de un
sabroso alimento los perros comenzaron a
salivar con solo el sonido de la campana
aunque no hubiera alimentos en el efecto
placebo una píldora sin sustancias
activas provoca una respuesta similar a
una píldora con sustancias lo que cambia
es nuestra reacción ante la dolencia
aunque la dolencia en sí no cambie o
piensen en el amor que sentimos por
nuestros padres podría decirse que es un
amor instintivo y es parcialmente cierto
pero eso no explica por qué los niños
que son adoptados más tarde en la vida
sienten el mismo amor por sus padres
adoptivos
el argumento conductista puede
explicarlo
un padre biológico o no se asocia
constantemente a cosas como alimento
afecto juegos y protección y una
asociación constante de los padres con
estos aspectos de la infancia tiene un
efecto similar aunque más complicado que
el alimento en los perros de pavlov en
otras palabras si nuestros padres
garantizan cosas muy buenas entonces
ellos mismos se tornan en algo muy bueno
también a elecciones románticas que
aprender de las observaciones de pavlov
todos necesitamos alimentos para
sobrevivir no alguien que pueda darnos
manjares exquisitos puede convertirse en
el equivalente humano de la campana es
decir si uno puede proveer platos
deliciosos para un potencial amor hay
probabilidades de ser visto de manera
más favorable en el futuro y quien no
quiere que el amor de su vida se ve con
eso pero también hay un lado oscuro en
este tipo de aprendizaje llamado
aversión al sabor la aversión al sabor
ocurre cuando ingerimos alimentos que
con el tiempo nos enferma
y en respuesta evitamos estos alimentos
a veces por el resto de la vida la
aversión al sabor es tan potente que sus
efectos pueden verse incluso si nos
enfermamos horas más tarde e incluso si
el alimento en sí no nos enferma por
ejemplo cuando tenemos gripe e ingerimos
alimentos momentos antes de vomitar en
este caso sabemos que el alimento no
provocó el vómito pero nuestro cuerpo no
lo sabe y la próxima vez que encontremos
ese alimento es probable que nos
neguemos a comerlo imaginen las
consecuencias de no cocinar bien en una
primera cita si el alimento enferma tu
pretendiente podría asociar esa
sensación no sólo con la comida sino con
tu comida en particular si el episodio
es traumático o si vuelve a ocurrir
la pareja potencial podría relacionarte
con las consecuencias al igual que los
perros de pavlov hacían con la campana y
el alimento
como dice el viejo refrán la forma más
rápida de llegar al corazón es por el
estómago suponiendo que no haya
intoxicaciones en el proceso